allora io ho una missione che è quella
di parlare di questo di questa parola
che comincia con la m e che di solito le
persone adulte non pronunciano per
pudore
mentre i vecchi bambini dicono con gusto
e ci ridono sopra devo dire che a questa
parola io ho dedicato addirittura un
museo
mi sono preso la briga di fare questo
perché reputavo che la merda fosse
veramente importante per la vita
dell'uomo
quindi adesso vi dimostro
per quale motivo sono arrivato a questo
passo dietro di me c'è la mia azienda
agricola che un'azienda che si occupa
principalmente di allevamento è
distribuita in diverse zone della
pianura padana si chiama kastel bosco
dove abbiamo 3.500 capi bovini che
servono per la produzione del grana
padano e del latte quindi che ne
facciamo 500 quintali al giorno e
produciamo anche il grana sapevamo cosa
fare ma invece delle 1500 quintali di
letame che uscivano tutti i giorni da
gli spinter i delle vacche avevamo
abbiamo qualche problema nella gestione
qualche criticità nasceva appunto è
infatti la merda è una cosa che se usata
in modo improprio può dare dei problemi
soprattutto per i nitrati che sono
contenuti che possono inquinare il
terreno è anche per le esalazioni di
metano
nell'atmosfera in senza dimenticare gli
odori
quindi alla fine ho cercato di risolvere
questi problemi che potevano sembrare
negativi in qualcosa di positivo e mi è
venuto incontro
la tecnica del biogas infatti il biogas
all'interno di questi di gestori noi
riusciamo governare la fermentazione
della sostanza organica dell'età me per
produrre metano
il metano poi viene portato liberato ai
motori che lo trasformano in megawatt
elettrici infatti noi produciamo 3
megawatt elettrici che sono sufficienti
per dare energia a un piccolo paese
anche di 3.000 persone
poi un'altra cosa vantaggiosa che deriva
sempre dalla merda è stato il calore il
calore che arriva dallo scambio termico
dei motori e che per noi serviva per
scaldare i digestori che devono essere
mantenuti a 40 gradi e anche per fare il
calore delle case dello stesso museo di
cui vi parlerò l'ultimo vantaggio in
questa parte è stata quella di
utilizzare il calore anche attraverso
degli essiccatoi che trasformavano in
questo materiale in uscita dai di
gestori in un concime organico che noi
abbiamo chiamato merda me è registrato
al ministero dell'agricoltura
infatti vedrete che abbiamo creato tutta
una linea di prodotti che derivano dalla
merda e dove cioè abbiamo persino
inventato il marmo finto che chiamiamo
mehr dorino allora ilmer da me è un
concime organico che a differenza dei
concimi chimici e dei valori assoluti
perché è rinnovabile mentre i concimi
chimici stanno per finire per dirvi il
fosforo nel 2020 prevedono che non ci
sarà più sulla terra perché sparirà la
roccia da cui viene estratto e poi
concimi chimici vengono fatti con
l'energia fossile vi faccio vedere una
foto appunto antica di concimi organici
che venivano che si chiamava guano che
ancora adesso c'è però queste erano
montagne che arrivano fino a 200 metri
fatte dagli uccelli marini di fron
nelle isole di fronte al perù però a
questo punto se avessi fatto solo questo
nessuno mi avrebbe preso in
considerazione perché tanti agricoltori
fanno alcune cose che ho fatto
precedentemente ma aver fondato il museo
della merda ha creato un po uno shock
lo shock è stato quello di mettere
insieme due parole completamente diverse
una era museo che una parola alta e
l'altra è merda che è una parola bassa e
volgare e bisogna fare una riflessione
sulla parola volgare cosa vuol dire
volgare volgare che corrisponde al reale
ha un'accezione che non è sempre
negativa in questo caso prendo giotto e
e dante che furono dei rivoluzionari in
questo nel loro campo nella pittura
nella letteratura e che giotto
attraverso cioè raffigurò il cristo come
una persona vera mentre precedentemente
veniva sempre idealizzato sulla croce
mentre invece dante che usava un lessico
molto variegato alto basso e medio medio
e basso nel nell'inferno utilizzò molte
volte la parola sterco alla fine hanno
parlato di arte perché l'arte mi ha
accompagnato un po in tutta la mia vita
come del resto l'agricoltura non amo
definirmi collezionista però un
ricercatore diciamo la e ho collaborato
con degli artisti che hanno trasformato
la mia azienda agricola in un in un
posto artistico devi 3m per esempio ha
colorato tutti i posti di lavoro e quali
e anima tripoli e hanno trasformato il
paesaggio in land art
lo vedete per esempio qui una foglia
un'aiola a forma di foglia di mais e
successivamente la questo traliccio che
è diventata un'opera d'arte che una
volta trasportava la corrente dalle
nell'azienda agricola e adesso invece
siamo noi che vendiamo alla corrente
elettrica all'enel e quindi l'aspetto
che mi ha fatto riflettere e stato
questo aspetto magico della
trasformazione continua dell'età maine
in energia elettrica la prima volta che
è successo mi sono sentito un mago e
alla fine dopo tante riflessioni
sul tema della natura l'agricoltura
l'arte nel 2015 insieme altri tre amici
massimo valsecchi luce luca cipelletti e
gasco e marco ne in pieno periodo expo
mentre tutti parlavano di cibo noi
parlavamo della della merda
ovviamente a questo punto non voglio
dilungarmi molto sul museo che l'unica
particolarità che è la differenza di
altri musei risiede sotto la mia casa
quindi posso dire che non vado al bar
sotto casa ma vado a vedere a fare un
giro al museo tante volte e quindi
vi lascio la curiosità per venirmi a
trovare personalmente quindi la comunque
il tema principale del museo è il tema
della trasformazione della rigenerazione
della metamorfosi
e a questo punto vorrei parlare
solamente dell'insetto che è il nostro
nostra mascotte che lo scarabeo
stercorario che mi è molto simpatico
perché è stato sempre stato vicino alla
merda e infatti lui gira sempre con una
pallina che è una pallina di mezza che è
un po un
un carrello della spesa è un passeggino
perché dentro ci mette i suoi i suoi
piccoli
un altro tema importante per me è sempre
stato quello agricolo quindi di
rivalutare l'aspetto agricolo e lo
scambio soprattutto fra l'agricoltura e
la cultura metropolitana e ho portato
due foto che rappresentano molto bene
questo aspetto cioè la nel periodo
fascista quando coltivavano il frumento
in mezzo a piazza del duomo a piazza
della repubblica
non tutti sanno per esempio che la
rivoluzione più importante del
settecento non fu quella francese o
quella industriale ma quella agricola
per che permise a maggior persone di
sopravvivere quindi di diventare attori
nella rivoluzione industriale
ma dopo tante cose avevamo già avevo un
altro problema di risolvere problema di
tutte quelle grandi tutto quello che
fuoriusciva ancora dei digestori che era
un altro prodotto che dovevo trasformare
rendere tutto più sostenibile a questo
punto ho inventato questo prodotto che
si chiama merda cotta cioè la merda
cotta cos'è è un mix di argilla
mischiata con punto letame la paglia e
c'è una piccola ricetta
industriale e mi permette di fabbricare
degli oggetti molto gradevoli che
servono per la vita di tutti i giorni
questi alcuni oggetti dal cesso che è
quello più iconico e che è molto potente
poi abbiamo fatto l'omaggio manzoni e
poi un parallelepipedo che adesso
esponiamo in una mostra a parigi e può
essere una seduta o un coffee table
infatti è anche stato selezionato per
diventare una panchina nel parco
principale di stoccolma
poi il c'è il cubo facciamo piatti
bicchieri vasi mattonelle e chi più ne
ha più ne metta
ma l'oggetto più estremo devo dire che
sono gli oggetti per la tavola infatti
quando ho venduto i primi piatti a
londra erano veramente felice perché lì
si è compiuto il ciclo della della cosa
abbiamo fatto molte esposizioni quindi è
un'azienda agricola che diventa museo
che diventa anche produttrice di cose
che fa esibizioni in giro per il mondo
perché siamo stati due volte a milano
nel 2015 con sheet show poi abbiamo
fatto scelte evolution quest'anno e poi
siamo andati a londra con un camion e
abbiamo trasportato tutta la merda cota
a orticolario dove abbiamo esposto tutti
i nostri vasi che sono stati molto
apprezzati perché effettivamente si
collocano in una fra la terracotta e la
plastica come appunto diceva il mio
predecessore sulla plastica noi siamo
contro la plastica e abbiamo creato
questo prodotto perché è validissimo per
esempio nei vasi a è più leggero della
terracotta e anche più bello perché la
merda da una certa sfumatura anche alle
cose e la plastica e molto e sappiamo
come ha raccontato prima che è
questo invece è stato il primo shift
show che abbiamo fatto cip ciop volevo
dire scusate è che l'abbiamo fatto a
londra
siamo diventati un riferimento mondiale
per tutti quelli che vogliono parlare di
questo argomento e siamo finiti un po su
tutti i giornali del mondo quindi se il
mio tentativo di migliorare questa
questa cosa che la merda fosse riuscito
penso che ci sia anche un messaggio
filosofico dietro che è quello di dire
che forse c'è speranza per tutti se ce
l'ha fatta la merda ce la facciamo tutti